me my brother chose to end his life by
suicide and it deeply impacted myself
and my parents and when i look back you
know my thoughts about myself and
whether the world was safe enough and i
could go make something of myself in it
had really shifted right you know i
really didn't have a knowledge of like
oh you think about yourself differently
or you have an internal dialogue that's
built around shame now and built around
shock and did you know i needed help
then and there's no
shame to that right in a sense right
like trauma makes us want to feel
ashamed so that we hide but we we
absolutely need help if it rises to the
point where we're not sleeping well
we're depressed we can't get it out of
our minds you know if one hurts one's
knee or you know one has a problem in
their lungs or like we go see
people to help us if trauma rises to the
level of overwhelming our coping skills
then our brain function changes and we
can't just think our way into changing
that back
[Music]
hello welcome to the pretty intense
podcast on the show today is paul conte
he's a physician and a psychiatrist and
he has a book out called trauma the
invisible epidemic couldn't be more well
put than that title of the book you know
obviously the conversation is about
trauma really helping people understand
what it is and understand how you get it
how it's passed on i mean the fact that
it's
generational through epigenetics
he explains
that whole scenario and then also
healing therapies and modalities that
can be used whether you have no money
and
no resources to go outside of you
wherever you live or if you do and the
great therapies that are available and
just the effect that the world's having
on us right like it's a real thing i
mean
we don't live in a world where it's easy
to navigate and not stay out of a
vigilant high beta brain state of
fear and
concern and
um and just how to how we can be more
responsible for that and develop
agency and sovereignty over ourselves
these are some real keys to freedom so i
hope you enjoy this conversation uh
please hit subscribe if you like the
show or maybe other shows and i'd love
to hear you in the comments you know
what you think what do you want to hear
more about thanks for stopping by and
enjoy the show well i'm flattered that
you i'm flattered that you watch racing
and that you
are a fan and
but like i said if you just knew how
much i loved psychology i just got done
reading the body keeps the score okay
that's how much i love psychology it's a
pretty dense book so if you you read it
you really you really are interested no
doubt yeah it took a little while to get
through it i was slowly but surely
chipping away at it but
um and it is dense there's a lot of
information a lot of data um but so much
good information which is going to lead
to some of the questions today because
it's there was some compelling stuff um
but i thought maybe the best place to
start would be to kind of jump in it's a
common question i bet you get but i also
want you to add in your perspective on
um on on another side of it which is
defining trauma but maybe first start
off by
what you think people define trauma of
because
with the fact that i mean you're you're
the title of your book like the
invisible
epidemic trauma being the invisible
epidemic people don't quite understand
it so maybe what do people think it is
and then what is it for real so often
times when people
think about it and talk about trauma
what often comes to mind is like oh
anything that's negative right and and
that can lead to to kind of two extremes
right one can be to really minimize and
say hey everybody has negative things
right everyone's everyone's traumatized
in some way and then that can lead
people to sort of discount it right on
the other end if we're painting with too
much of a broad brush there are people
who then
want to say you know every child gets a
trophy or you know we want to stop we
want to start then protecting people
from any adversity right so so trauma is
not you know
anything with a clinical trauma right
it's not anything that's negative right
it is something that is that is negative
in a way that overwhelms our coping
skills right so if it overwhelms our
ability to take it in our ability to
cope with what that trauma is then there
are changes in our brains right so it's
not just like oh it's anything negative
no it's something that rises to the
level where our brain function right and
therefore our psychology right which
which rides upon our brain function is
different going forward and there's
there's hard scientific evidence
about this so it's not a soft
concept right like we know that for
example vigilance mechanisms in the
brain change right after trauma the true
trauma that overwhelms our coping
mechanisms and leaves us different going
forward that all sorts of things shift
inside of us including genetic changes
where it can change how active or not
active
our genes are when we pass them on years
later right to be think about that it's
grounded in the cutting edge of science
but we but we are not applying that
cutting edge of science in our
understanding of like what's going on in
the world around us in our societies and
what's going on in each of us
so you're saying that so you can have
two people experience the same thing
trauma same same adversity and one
registers at it as an actual trauma and
one doesn't correct
right right and even in the same person
there's something called say the
multiple hit hypothesis which might say
that i might have three four five
traumas maybe right and and they could
look pretty significant from the outside
but they don't overwhelm my coping
mechanisms and change my brain as i go
forward then there might be another one
that might even be much smaller say less
than the magnitude the previous ones and
that could push a person into now having
basically a post-trauma syndrome so it
varies by person what are our genetics
and are we are genetics protective or do
they make liability for us what is our
prior life experience been what support
mechanisms do we have around us so it
varies across people and it can also
vary within
a person where it might be that fourth
fifth sixth trauma that can then make a
syndrome that didn't occur with the
first wow
how
just to give more insight like given
maybe an anecdotal situation of of
something that would be perceived
to anyone as small like how small can
something get
for the body to register it as a trauma
well i mean theoretically it could get
quite small
very small if
that if the person is particularly
susceptible right so if you imagine
someone who's been in just dire
circumstances right and and they've
gotten through them without being
overwhelmed say the person is made for
being a refugee and you know trying to
escape syria and get from one place to
another and just makes it through and
then gets to a place where seemingly
like okay now
i'm safe right i'm out of i'm out of the
danger right and then imagine in
environments like that if there's some
sort of chronic denigration where the
person is now seen as less than you know
they're ethnically different their
socioeconomic status is different that
that could push someone to to then
oppose trauma syndrome even though one
might think there's nothing even
dramatic going on happening anymore
right right but but you know so much of
what goes on with us like it all goes on
inside of us right and then we we have
to live with the experiences that happen
inside of us and how they
impact us which which is why we need a
health care system that's actually
paying attention to what's going on
inside of us talking to us about it
right as opposed to seeing all of us the
same i mean i think you know the the the
what we've been talking about so far is
like really important right because it's
acknowledging the difference across
human beings that hey we're not all the
same right we don't have the same
genetic makeup we don't have the same
experiences we don't react the same way
and if we look at us all the same right
how are we gonna help any of us and and
that's also you know in writing a book
that i wish to be accessible to anyone
right who chooses to pick it up and read
it and entertaining and engaging that
writes about these things in into the
common plain
language right it's so that we can gain
an understanding
not just of what it is but of how do we
prevent it i mean that's ultimately what
we wish to do or how do we recognize it
if it's present how do we treat it
because the systems around us the
medical
systems and mental health care systems
um are doing such a poor job
of that what are kind of the
environmental circumstances that lead to
someone since obviously everyone
registers things different and even that
person individually themselves can
register it different over time or
through repetition
what is it that
what is it that um
that makes your nervous system
uh able to
cope better what are some skills that
would allow you to cope better with
things so that things don't register as
a trauma is that even possible
yeah sure sure you know anything that
that
can put us in lower states of
vulnerability right so if you think i
mean how many people are going through
life even before the pandemic right in
in a state of fairly constant
vulnerability right you know i remember
reading before the pandemic
all this great news about how the
unemployment rate is so low right but
then you would also see news that would
say some really astronomical percentage
of people where they can't survive and
move forward as they're living if they
have like a five or six hundred dollar
expense right and then you think okay
you know we're sort of celebrating that
that there's a low unemployment rate but
but so many people are employed in
sectors where they just can't get ahead
right i mean you think about the service
industry and like how hard it is
maybe even approaching impossible to do
things people could do in the past ready
to buy a home send children to to
college if they choose right
that as all of that changes what ends up
happening is it builds vulnerability
into the system where now people's
medical benefits are tied to a job that
they could lose right or they have a job
but their job doesn't have medical
benefits and you need a job to have
medical benefits or at least you have
historically right in this country we're
doing somewhat of a better
job at that now but you know these
states of vulnerability which can also
come by feeling denigrated in in any way
whether that's because of socioeconomic
status or it's it's around gender or
sexuality right there there's so many
ways in which people are sort of
chronically
denigrated right and and feel a sense of
being less than and and like that that
really doesn't help at all with our
resilience mechanisms when something
traumatic happens and the more we're
interconnected with other people there's
friends and family and support networks
around us you know things that we had a
lot more in the past that we now have a
lot
less of so so absolutely we can do
things to predispose us to handle
traumatic things well so that they don't
leave us different going forward right
but unfortunately a lot of what's
happened in the world around us
only brings more vulnerability and
predisposes us to to the negative
reactions inside of us through traumatic
things and how many people have lost
their lives right so how many people are
are
now trying to go forward with lost loved
ones and
feeling a sense of vulnerability they
never felt before and we have such an
angry and often heartless political
dialogue around us that can can we can
we
blame anyone if most people are feeling
beleaguered and then what are we doing
we're just making soil that's fertile
for the seeds of trauma to fall whether
that's a car accident or it's a death of
a loved one or it's loss of a job or
it's any of the other
millions of things that can that can
happen to us we we create fertile ground
for the seeds of trauma to change our
brains to release shame to create fear
in us and to make life worse for us
going forward and i don't think that's
esoteric i mean i think that that's the
common sense read of what's going on
around us i mean i'm trying to put some
structure to it in the book and in this
conversation but i also think that it's
just
eminently obvious just looking at the
world around us what a great perspective
the word that comes to mind the whole
time is
sovereignty
and how
i think i feel like we're all being
called into sovereignty over our bodies
over our minds and that there's so much
being pushed on us that it's like it
kind of
um
is at a breaking point or being it's
we're being pushed so hard that we need
to step into that does that register is
that the right way of thinking about it
yeah i mean most people are pushed
really hard after these last couple of
years right and most people were pushed
really hard before these last couple of
years i mean look you need look no
further than the opiate epidemic and how
many thousands upon thousands upon
thousands of people
died
needlessly right and how much of that
was desperation when you know the
opiates after the surgery oh didn't just
help the knee pain right but they helped
a greater kind of pain right it kind of
pain inside that then created a
dependence that ended up killing that
person and as someone who's done a lot
of work in that realm over years and
years it's just tragic because it's the
opiate epidemic yes it was a symptom of
many many things
but one of the things it was a symptom
of was the desperation that's getting
built into
all of us right it's getting built into
us as americans and we're not doing a
good job of taking care of ourselves
resources are squandered right we don't
look around us like how can we use our
resources as a society better how can we
use health care resources to actually
treat our health i mean you you look at
what's going on and you say in a way
it's exactly what one would expect right
you know if we all live together on a
street and we said let's not take care
of it anymore right let's have potholes
in the street and who cares if they do
tree limbs fall off and kill somebody
and you know we'll fight with each other
too while we're doing it right are we
really going to be surprised if we run
that forward and we're like wow some of
us are dead right a lot of us are really
at risk or unhappy we're at odds and
like this street that might have been a
lovely place to live before is now going
you know going downhill and it's not for
lack of resources right it's just that
the resources are squandered or we're
just looking at everything through a
lens of
anger and frustration and there's so
much of that in the world where where
you think about the idea of like
the lack of attachment to truth into
fact right which is you know as a guy
who was a political science major and
followed politics for so many years like
at least people would would like agree
if there was a fact like you know if i
were saying one plus one is three and
you're saying it's two and you can show
me that it's two right you know i think
in the past i was unlikely to double
down and say you know what it's three
anyway right and now i'll attack you
personally right i mean like why you
know
when we do that we
we work so strongly against our own
interests and so much of that comes
because people are just angry and this
is this is how it gets if we're afraid
and we're angry we just want to be right
right and we don't care if we're
actually right or not we just want to
assert ourselves and and say we're right
no matter what and have that feeling
inside and i see so much of that where
there's allegedly political dialogue but
if you do what i do for a living you
watch some of that and you say this is
too angry people talking
right
right and and getting angrier as they're
talking and then there's almost a pride
in being unattached to facts well well
guess what it's unattached to facts that
leaves hundreds of thousands of people
dead through the opiate epidemic it
leaves hundreds of thousands of people
needlessly dead from covet that has the
resources being sucked out of the
systems that are supposed to help us and
you know i'm not trying to do say right
but i'm saying like look at this and
let's look at where this is going and it
clearly can't be anywhere good i mean
i'm based in portland oregon and over
the summer it was hotter than it is in
death valley here right i mean we have
to look at the world around us and say
you know their problems with the climate
their their their problems across the
board from from how we function as
societies from small to large to how the
planet is functioning it's like it's
common sense for us to look at that
well
we're just probably fractal in nature
anyway so the micro is the macro
right and it's like i feel like when you
start taking care of yourself better you
start taking care of other people better
and it's just kind of
ends up being a reaction what i was
thinking about was like i wonder is
is
the
the deep anchoring and the cognitive
dissonance around subjects and the
inability to decide to be able to say
maybe it is too
uh is there is there so much more
anchoring and anger
as a result of actually
trauma being activated or is it
more
fear
i'm curious that i just that sprung to
mind and i was like man is this actually
like trauma activation happening with
people
sure absolutely
so many i mean if you you look into the
backgrounds or the life histories when
people are are very
um
negative disruptive right like you know
negative or harmful forces in the world
around us whether that's in big ways or
it's just in the hey i don't care who's
right i want to have my way right
you know when you look underneath of
that that very often there is trauma not
always right but but i've learned over
20 years of doing what i do
that if you look for trauma you very
often find the answer right why is that
person not stopped drinking after five
residential rehab stays right why is
this person still depressed after so
much depression treatment right why why
can't this person sleep right and we
have such a reflex it says we'll give
them more antidepressants give them more
sleeping medicine but we don't look at
why right and so
often i mean so often if you engage in a
process of exploration of dialogue what
you find is that yes
trauma is underlying those problems but
what but trauma makes a reflex of shame
in us we feel guilt and shame and
anxiety and fear and then it changes our
ability to see
right what has happened to us so so you
think there's very there's very
if it's hard to imagine a worse enemy
right than an enemy that changes how you
think right and makes you feel a sense
of guilt and a sense of shame and a
sense of being beleaguered which often
makes a sense of defensiveness which can
lead to a sense of digression sometimes
right and that you don't even know the
difference
right and that's often what trauma does
to us you know i told this story of a
young woman who before of an acute
terrible trauma you know saw herself as
somebody who could navigate the world
right and she was a bright and engaging
and people liked her and you know people
she was interested in dating wanted to
date her and she had education
opportunities and that she thought well
of herself and then she won an award at
some point you know i think back even in
high school for like being smart and
great about something you know and and
it was like how she thought of her so
she kind of anchored herself to like hey
that thing was great right and it shows
like i can go do what i try to do even
though you know they were she had a lot
to get going against her she was trying
to navigate the world right then after
the trauma
her whole story changes and she doesn't
know it
right it changes it no one likes me no
one will ever love me i'll never have a
good relationship i can't make my way
into work oh and that award it was a
life laughing at me right here's the
best you're ever going to do with
yourself even though you're in high
school this award that someone gave to
me even i didn't deserve it right i mean
it all changed in her and by the way
i've seen this over and over and over
it's just it's just one very clear
example without her having any
understanding and say like wait is that
how you felt about yourself before
this is truth what do you mean it's of
course it's how i feel about myself look
you know i've known you for years you
never felt like this before right then
we can start to begin exploring that and
that happens in us with traumas often
that extend back to childhood but but
you're not always they don't always have
to go back to childhood but they often
do
and they change the way that we're
functioning the way that we're taking
care of ourselves the way that we're
interacting with other people and often
we don't know it which is why you know i
have an entire clinic where we we take
care of people from the clinical and
consulting perspectives and trying to
help them understand themselves and so
often how do we help people get better
is we look at the their history and what
they're saying to themselves and what
their life narratives are and what the
role of trauma might be
and it just makes sense you know where
we're moving towards vending machine
medicine of like just give me an
inventory of your symptoms right and
without making eye contact i'll flick a
medicine back to you i mean how could
that work right and
does that make sense out of i was saying
a lot about it but it's a hundred
percent i
it's just it's the roots of it like you
can keep like putting a band-aid on a
bullet hole but like it's got to fix the
problem at some point in time and
what is your opinion on
because i i mean maybe i should go back
my experience is everyone has trauma on
some level it might not be manifesting
in a really big way in your life it
might be like and it can be really you
know comes from simple places
um but there is definitely like an
aspect of the self-help community that
uh would say i don't think this isn't
like a a psychologist's uh
perspective i don't think cause this not
the point of the actual job but that
there's a bypassing that you can just
out think it you can just choose what
feels good and that is i feel like
there's a rise in that but there's also
a rise in practices that you have and i
remember having a conversation with my
mom
and just talking about something and
some issue that she had had and i was
like hey you know did you and dad ever
think about going to therapy and she
went no
right like it was
you only went if you were a psychopath
right or if you had
like some kind of really terrible
manifested depression that made you
debilitated to some level right but i
feel like there's also a rise to
going to therapy i go to therapy i
sometimes have two therapists at once
like
i love the work
um so i'm just curious what's your
opinion because both of them are on the
rise but i think there's some bypassing
happening if you act like you can solve
your problems by just make pretending
like they're not there
absolutely i mean i i would say this i
still say this a lot but i would say
this when i was teaching all the time
that lucas there's like three kinds of
people right so people who have real
mental health problems right bad
depression um bad ptsd with panic
attacks right or any kind of post trauma
syndrome ptsd is just one of them right
so they're people of real mental health
problems right they're people who aren't
alive right and the rest of us all have
mental health issues
right i mean it's complicated to
navigate the world right it's
complicated to go forward with all the
things that happen to us right and if
someone comes in our door and they don't
have a post-trauma syndrome they haven't
made changes in their brain but they've
had issues of like this stressor or that
stressor this trauma or that trauma
right but not big enough to change the
brain well guess what that's worth
talking about too yeah right i mean i go
to psychotherapy
weekly as well and have for years and
years and and like sometimes i have
something problematic to talk about but
if not i mean my goodness there there's
enough in my life
right that it could help me function
better so this idea that like we can all
benefit from grounding to ourselves and
what's going on inside of us what are
the stressors and what are the decisions
that we're making absolutely and then we
can shift back and forth between having
a problem and having issues right so as
i wrote about in the book that i wrote
after my brother's suicide i had
real problems i mean my brother chose to
end his life by suicide and it deeply
impacted myself and my parents and when
i looked back i had no mental health
background i was lucky that i had people
around me who were helpful and
supportive right and and helped me get
through it but you know my thoughts
about myself and whether the world was
safe enough and i could go make
something of myself in it had really
shifted right i knew something was
different i knew something was wrong i
wasn't taking care of myself like i did
before and i was unhappy and i was
depressed i was not just unhappy i went
for that to depress it i was drinking
too much and you know and
you know i really didn't have a
knowledge of like oh you think about
yourself differently or you have an
internal dialogue that's built around
shame now and built around shock and
you know i needed help then and there's
no
shame to that right in a sense right
like trauma makes us want to feel
ashamed so that we hide it's it that's
like you know that's
the ultimate in evil right that the
thing that you need help with creates
shame that makes you hide it
right but we we absolutely need help if
it rises to the point we're not sleeping
well we're depressed we can't get it out
of our minds then we need to go and get
some
help and when we do
it can change things just like you know
if one hurts one's knee or you know one
has a problem in their lungs or like we
go see
people to help us and it's no different
i mean if you imagine
how if is okay i'll give an example how
after certain if trauma rises to the
level of overwhelming our coping skills
right then our brain function changes
like we were talking about earlier right
and we can't just think our way into
changing that back right is this anxiety
well it gets to be it's more than just
anxiety it can manifest itself as
anxiety but there are automatic things
that go on in the brain so for example
the idea of like how do we react if we
if we're not on the other side of trauma
that's overwhelmed or coping mechanisms
when we see a new person right is we we
look at that person and we look for for
interest like do you look interested in
me do you look benign right do you look
like you might have something to offer
in a conversation right we look for
other at other people with a sense of of
curiosity right and interest in them
after trauma in the way that get
overwhelms our copings those were
different going forward then we're
looking at other people through the lens
of vigilance mechanisms which is really
like are you going do you mean me harm
right the thing about that's not the
best way to go through
life if we're trying to like do the best
we can at our job right or people are
trying to find someone to have a
relationship with or you know whatever
it may be even like meeting a new
neighbor if you know if we automatically
say i see you i don't know you and i
automatically thinking are you trying to
harm me right
that is so different than the kind of
openness
right that we feel
if we're not in that situation and the
idea that we're just going to think our
way out of it right it's just like it's
not how that works no more than if
someone has an acl tear and you think
i'm just going to look at it like this
until it fixes itself right
right so so if we recognize what's going
on inside of us and we look at what's
our internal dialogue what are we saying
to ourselves right as the day
goes along right what's our life
narrative what do i think of my life
what kind of story would i tell right
these are the ways that we start to get
in touch with what's going on inside of
us so that we can again be empowered
right like you said sovereignty or what
sometimes is called agency of like look
i've got i'm in charge of myself right
i'm an adult and i'm in charge of myself
in a world that doesn't make that easy
right so i want to be at my best which
means i want to understand myself as
best i can what do i have going for me
right i don't want to see myself through
the lens of guilt and shame and fear and
anxiety right that comes on the other
end of
of trauma if that makes sense yeah yeah
a few kind of words like a cluster of
sort of concepts come together
like
victim victim mentality
accountability
and so i'm kind of curious
if
there is a subconscious awareness like
i'm curious about people that don't want
to heal too like that can realize that
their life is kind of a mess and they
don't want to figure it out but i wonder
if that shame and the things that people
feel if underlying there is a
because here's the thing i know i'm
talking around around around i'm not
being clear right now
in therapy i was told because i wanted
some healing from some issues with my
dad and
and my therapist said that nobody holds
the keys for you and i was like oh
and like
there's a it's a
it's a level of accountability that i
was overwhelmed by for a second i was
like oh [ __ ] this is all my fault
meaning like sorry not my fault but my
responsibility your traumas are not your
fault but your healing is your
responsibility
and it's not easy and it's not
necessarily quick
um but essential for moving forward and
having a next level of joy and happiness
and freedom
and and agency as you said and so i
wonder if there's just a lot of people
that are actually really comfortable to
be
in a victim mentality because i think
that's also
its own little epidemic of like victim
mentality
right
i think there are a couple of things
that can go on there and make that
unfortunately very widespread right one
is so if trauma
makes guilt and shame right and
decreases our sense of agency right then
then it follows that we're much more
likely to hide from it right the idea
being that to make our lives better we
have to take chances right
even the chance of like let me stop and
think about what's going on in my head
right let me write down what's going on
in my head let me talk to somebody about
what's going on inside me let me admit
something right that might not be the
most pleasant thing to admit trauma
tells us not to do that right it just
hide it away because it says you should
be ashamed of it i mean how many times
have i seen people who you know person
who was assaulted right and knows that
like that they did nothing wrong but
they can't get around that feeling that
it's their fault they should have
dressed differently walked in a
different place right and like that's
what's in their head right and it's
driving shame and then they don't want
to go talk to someone about that right
or childhood abuse i mean for goodness
sakes it creates so much to stress and
change i can't tell anyone that right
and then we hide ourselves from
the helping resources so the fact that
that trauma makes guilt shame insecurity
anxiety vulnerability leads us to do the
opposite right of what we would do or
should do to help ourselves so that's
part of it is that people since
accidentally painted into a corner right
and and if we had more trusting
resources how many people say oh and i
tried to get some help and again i'm not
trying to be negative to the the people
who are trying to do the helping right
but if one works in a system where
you're seeing four people an hour you
can't stop and listen to people you
can't hear their story you can't have
follow-up appointments in a reasonable
amount of time then of course people
feel unheard right and then they go and
they're trying to maybe taking that
chance maybe you'll talk to me and and
then they come away with some medicine
that doesn't work because no one talked
to them so the medicine of course isn't
going to fix the problem and then the
system is saying oh they failed the
medicine i mean great i mean
it makes no
sense right and then the other aspect
can be
the idea that embracing a victim role
is is also a power position to be in and
say hey because i
i feel victimized right now i'm sort of
standing outside of of criticism right
you know you can't criticize what i'm
doing or saying right because i'm
identifying that way right which is not
helpful either right because when people
internalize victimhood i i don't mean in
a sense of like if someone does
something to someone that's criminal
you'd say okay that person is the victim
right right there's a difference between
that as just a descriptive term
right and how people actually feel
inside and it is never
never good
is never healthy to internalize the
victim say i feel like a victim i am a
victim right that that 100 of the time
takes away from our sense of agency our
ability to have sovereignty our ability
to marshal our resources right because
what you're describing happened to you
in therapy where like the light bulb
goes off and you're like oh this is my
responsibility right then you're able to
say okay well i'm going to marshal my
resources right like i've got
intelligence and thoughtfulness and
empathic attunement and i can i can use
words and i can be open and honest and
then you feel empowered to go do that
thing to help that thing that is your
responsibility right which is which is
different i mean a person can't do that
if there's guilt and shame and such a
sense of vulnerability which is why you
can see that it's almost like trauma in
creating guilt and shame conspires with
our helping systems allegedly helping
systems right to actually keep people
from help because there's not a place
for most people to go and in a safe way
to talk about it and to come away with
an experiences like oh that helped me
i'm starting to put words around things
and what's the goal of all of it then
i'm healthier and stronger right for me
and for the people around me like it's
nothing but good it's not something that
i need to feel ashamed about for
goodness sakes it's actually the
opposite of that and that's what we see
here when we see so much change
in people not because it's magic or it's
even rocket science we're just applying
you know have all the arrows in the
quiver of how you approach someone to
try and understand and help them mm-hmm
yeah
i interviewed priyanka chopra a while
back and she said a line that i thought
was
so right on
and she said sadness is seductive and i
was like
wow that kind of hits like that that
feels real
um and so i'm wondering what happens
biochemically in your brain
that you stay in a loop or a pattern
which kind of might lead us into a
little bit of an anxiety conversation
because i'm really fascinated by anxiety
sure sure
well a lot of the changes in the brain
will come from the brain's efforts to
stay safe
right and and ultimately we're all
seeking safety right because it's only
from a place of safety that we can go
out and do the things that we wish to do
in the world i mean my guess is that in
your career right that you're feeling
that hey you had a good team around you
and you had a good car look so
everything was as good and as safe as it
can be right then it lets you go out and
be at your best right and if you didn't
feel safe right you felt actively unsafe
how could you go out and in a sense fire
on all cylinders and be your best right
oh yeah yeah absolutely
and that's what we're really all looking
to do that if we can't build safety that
look i can go out my front door and i'm
not terrified of every person that i
meet because all i'm doing is threat
sensing right or if i'm not living in a
world that says hey you know good news
you know you're employed um everything
is great but but you know hey i don't
have health benefits somebody gets sick
or car breaks down i can't survive right
you know just examples or that one is
is constantly denigrated or seen as less
than by society right and when's the
next time a person is going to look at
me and see me in that way or not give me
a job or an opportunity based upon
whether it's gender identity sexual
orientation socioeconomic ethnic
religious whatever it may be right we
need to create safety in our society in
rational ways so that we can then go out
there and be the best we can be and this
idea that we're going to go do that
while we're beleaguered inside right and
why while we feel we have all these
effects of trauma that tell us that
we're not safe how do we expect to do
that and how do we think that that's not
going to lead to more anxiety to
depression to sleep changes to physical
health changes right because more than
half the complaints people go to
physical medicine doctors are coming
from mental health places right from
mental health issues stressors right so
you know if we don't have systems that
acknowledge this and we're so concerned
with throughput and we're so rapid fire
and fast then we're not actually helping
anyone help themselves and then we just
run along headlong you know we run
headlong forward into more and more
dysfunction as trauma accumulates and
more and more people are not helped and
the resources get sucked out of the
healthcare system so i don't know if
that was a good
answer to it but yeah i think so because
you know if we don't have
you know we don't have a safe place if
we can't be ourselves then you know we
kind of stay stuck in a way right right
in a frame there's no there's no there's
no freedom there's no there's no space
like you're just sort of tight
and
um
yeah i it does it does
um
so one of the things you mentioned
earlier was genetics i'm kind of
fascinated by genetics
epigenetics and how all of that stuff
works so
what
the hell do we do if we're
if we have
genetics passed on
and like what does it actually what
actually has to happen to mark a genetic
change within you that then makes you be
the beginning of a new coding
is that
you can change that within you that then
passes on and that's what you're saying
right right it determines whether a gene
is active or not so there may be a gene
that is this epigenetic but is that
epigenetics
okay so this isn't genetic so i think
people need to know the difference
because
um
because it yeah i think that's important
it doesn't mean that you're actually
changing your gene coding it's that
you're you're
essentially activating and deactivating
certain codes and that's epigenetics yes
right right right and a lot of the
activation or deactivation is is within
the the sequence of codes in the genetic
material right so that it's kind of
complicated what is it changing
what is it not changing right but but
but the but what it is changing is is
that gene active in you and then and the
idea would be there may be a gene that's
active across generations right that we
think oh that that person or that that
person has that gene that's come down to
them right and then
trauma you know the trauma that
overwhelms us changes our coping
mechanisms makes makes changes in our
brain can then change whether a gene is
on or off so so it can mean it's as if
you didn't have it right so imagine
there's a good gene and you've got that
gene to pass on right you've got that
gene to pass along but if something
happens and now it's turned off as if
you don't have it well you're gonna you
pass it on in that way right
and in the book i i have two interviews
in my book one is with darren richarder
who is a psychiatrist who works in
trauma and trauma research at stanford
and darren speaks to the science behind
this and he's done really seminal work
around this so so for example it was
thought at one point that say rape as a
tool of war right was a criminal thing
that happened in a one-time event right
like that thing was wrong and we're
gonna look at it as criminal and it
happened on that day at that time and
like that's that and it was bad right
and now through lots of people's work
including in the epigenetic realm but
darren is a person who's who's
synthesized a lot of this together you
know now
there's a there's a different
appropriately different view of that
which is that act on that day rape as a
tool of war changes that person's life
for the rest of their life it impacts
that community for the rest of that
person's life and it impacts his
generate it impacts generations to come
right so in the case of that woman may
not be become pregnant and have a child
until seven years later right but that
event changes
how she is going to pass on her genes
years later right so
it starts to validate that like this is
real like ancestral trauma like i was
gonna ask about that too but here it is
right right because how does that happen
as we keep passing along those genes
right and on the one hand you say okay
we're we're passing on genes a lot of
that is about survival right but but
survival isn't necessarily consistent
with optimization right if too much
that's going on in us is just about
survival well maybe we do become more
fragmented right as as humans we maybe
we do trust each other less that we
we keep creating trauma in in our
societies as we then pay those genes
forward right and what are we doing to
ourselves across
generations and there's the second
interview is with a woman named
stephanie von gutenberg who is a german
uh child wellness and child health
advocate and she's a tremendous amount
of expertise on childhood traumas it's
just it's the most dramatic way of
seeing like what trauma does to us to
people as we move across the life span
and when you combine her writing about
early childhood trauma and then darren
richard you know in the interview with
him around transgenerational trauma then
the idea is really to provide the full
you know to provide the full perspective
and then i'm filling in what's in the
middle of you know what happens to us
when our coping skills are overwhelmed
what changes in our brains how does it
affect our bodies how does it affect our
memory our memories you know so the idea
is to really in an engaging way to talk
about that whole continuum from
childhood through transgenerational
aspects wow yeah well somebody you need
to know what to do right you need to
know if you have ancestral trauma you
don't necessarily know because this
whole
aspect of being a human and not being
able to see yourself is kind of a real
thing like yes the mirroring aspect of
the world is a critical uh critical
element and so writing a book that
that
gives people
those um
triggers almost to
activate like oh i kind of deal with
that that's critical i mean that's
important
yes
what do you think about
what do you think about gene therapy or
crispr things like that that can go in
and edit genes
or change the coding is that anything
that you think will make its way into
your field but if so i think that'd be a
long way down the road you know we're
still trying to figure out you know how
to change like one specific gene if we
know for example in medicine that okay
there's an illness and that illness is
tied to one gene
right
we're still really trying to figure out
how did you repair that one gene like
you know it's so so what is it right
well it's right so and sometimes we can
we know which genes oh really that's
right and and it's still difficult to go
in and try and fix that i mean it just
highlights the complexity right that you
know we each one of us
is more complicated than like you know
everything else on earth that's not
another human being right so that you
know so we've learned so much and people
have just done just tremendously
brilliant
research you know carl dice roth who's a
a friend and a former colleague who went
to medical school who who's done so much
in this area you know epigenetics and
neuroscience and and they're just so
many people who are doing wonderful work
but it's so complicated i think we're a
long way from being able to inter
intervene in things that are that are
polygenic because there's multiple genes
involved right we need to get to where
we can say oh that illness is
related to that one gene and we can
identify that gene and change it right
and we're still sort of figuring
that out
so would you
is it of your opinion that
maybe it might not come from genes and
maybe this is a this is an element of
consciousness
yeah i i think
that that how we help people is is
really coming from the meta phenomena
like we we understand
that changes can happen in the brain and
there are times i can really soothe that
at least in the short term with medicine
so for example if after trauma the the
vigilance centers are hyperactive right
and a person can't even engage in
therapy right or maybe not engage in
their life right then we can use
medicines to try and get at the
underlying neurobiology right and it's
great to do that when it's indicated
right it's not great to throw medicines
at everything but it's great to utilize
medicines when
we can tell okay they really make sense
to treat something that's come of trauma
right
but what is all that in service of right
it's in service of being able to talk
about it right being able to apprehend
the feelings inside of us the thoughts
inside of us because you know the most
powerful parts of our part of our brain
is the limbic system right the emotion
system right this idea that we're
logical creatures right and like oh we
should just be logical about things is
is it completely untrue right like we
have logical systems in us but it's
utterly untrue that well you think i'll
give this example where think about a
lot the logical systems in our brain
never say it's a good idea to run inside
into a burning building
right right right but if like a loved
one is in the burning building right
like people running people do that and
do it without a second thought right
because when the logic systems and the
emotion systems come head to head the
emotion systems win
which they say i don't care what logic
is drama which is trauma
right right so if trauma is impacting
those emotion systems right and now
they're vigilant or they're mistrustful
and they see ourselves in a negative
shameful light right it doesn't matter
what the logic systems say which is why
more times that i could possibly count
how many times have i seen including in
myself where i would say oh i could see
that for somebody else right but not for
for me right
because the emotion systems will say no
i should i'm special in the sense that i
should feel ashamed about this right and
i actually feel like this is my fault
and i've seen that so many times for
persons if it were someone else they
know what they would say to that person
right and they know how they would help
them but they can't do it with
themselves right and that's why we need
to think we need to write we need to
talk to people right we need the
opportunities to help us get over the
the things that are in the meta
phenomena the psychology right which is
how we interface with ourselves right
and how we interface with the world
around us and if we're ignoring all of
this while we're running headlong right
then is it any surprise that we trip and
get hurt right the example i might use
here is like you know imagine a sprinter
right in a 100 meter race i mean you had
to come out of those blocks in a way
that's like very well telegraphed and
that person has to be great at doing
that but if they just launch themselves
out they will fall headlong forward
right and that's so much of what we're
doing we're rushing headlong forward as
a society we're not taking care of
ourselves and we're just rushing and
rushing and rushing and then it's like
we're like sort of psychologically
trampling ourselves you know on the way
and then we're surprised we're like oh
violence rates are up suicide rates are
up opiate dependence rates are up you
know we we handled the pandemic so
dysfunctionally that hundreds of
thousands of us died who didn't need to
and now we have to deal with all of that
right in everyone else living who's
dealing with that trauma i mean we're
not even taking good care of family
members of people who died in 9 11
right i mean why wouldn't we we that we
can't stop and look and say let's use
our resources for things that are good
for all of us or people to whom we feel
indebted right we're rushing along
headlong
and
you know we're close to the point where
we were having trouble taking care of
ourselves
as a society and you just see it in the
conflict around us and it's not that
hard to look at it and say hey if we
can't get a healthy grounding in
responsibility right responsibility to
rational communication responsibility to
truth responsibility to the idea that
like guess what i might be wrong now and
then or we might have different opinions
and like you could be a good person even
though we disagree right i mean if we
can't take these responsibilities how
are we going to take care of ourselves
as a society and i just see that there's
a common sense to it that on the one
hand yes there's complex neurobiology to
all of it on the other hand there's just
common sense of anchoring to the value
system right in our religious traditions
right you know in our
uh you know what science and medicine
tell us right even in early childhood
education right i mean i have young kids
and so often what what they're seeing
you know the seven-year-old what she's
seeing going on you know in the world
around us if she sees media like totally
doesn't fit with what she's learning now
in second grade
right so like how are we supposed to
teach kids like here's a simple way to
behave when they they look and they see
well that's not what i'm seeing
you know in the world around me and you
know we if we root ourselves to in many
ways to common sense the common sense of
science medicine or religious traditions
or early education we can start taking
better care of ourselves and that can
start for each of us today i mean
everyone can think what's going on
inside of me everyone can be just a
little bit nicer to other people today
which i don't think is some pollyanna
bleeding heart thing to say i mean if i
feel really pushed and and beleaguered
right and i can do something nice for
you if you you know drop something at
the checkout line or a smile to someone
to you know who maybe the person at the
checkout line you drop something smile
at that person instead of frown right i
mean it helps that person and it reminds
us that hey you know what there's good
in me
right i'm not just so be leaguer that i
can't access any good in me because if i
can't access it for other people i'm not
going to be able to access it for myself
either a hundred percent well said that
was a good feel right that was good
thank you thank you
i appreciate it
uh i think that will hit home for a lot
of people i think that hits home to the
truth of the reality of our existence
right now and it kind of makes me feel
you know makes me think about
mindfulness practices and how
you know you know
getting your body into a parasympathetic
mode and that you know if you were to
walk out of yoga class or a meditation
or a nap even right
you're not going to react to this the
world in the same way that if you just
got done doing
you know simultaneously doing six
different things while being pulled in
this direction and your phone's going
off and the news is talking about dramas
and there's bombs going off on the
screen like you're not going to respond
to the world the same way if that's your
brain state of high beta brain state of
vigilance and that's right
i think that that's a really important
thing for people to understand what are
the um
what are some of the uh
tools that you love in your practice to
i feel like you know maybe explaining
something that somebody could do at home
without a therapist but then also then
some of the things that you love in your
own practice and one of which came
through big time in um in the
um body keeps the score as emdr so
i'm just curious about that
yeah
you know in the book i i there are a lot
of stories because i think the stories
are meant to engage people and and you
know some of them person can relate to
and some not but the idea is to engage
people around like the the the truth of
it the reality of it and i think that
there there's guidance that comes
through the stories and there are
antidotes you know throughout the book
and just simple things that we can do so
i think the stories and the antidotes
provide a lot of that and a lot of it
are things that we can do ourselves
right so again just
showing some good will to someone else
doing something nice to ourselves is the
same thing show do some goodwill outward
treat ourselves a little bit better
inward right relaxation
exercises right guided imagery right i
mean these are things that we can do and
do alone they're free they're easy and
they and they help us feel
they can help us feel so much better and
and taking stock like what is our life
narrative right like what do i think of
myself in my life and it's fascinating
that often that we're not doing that and
when a person starts to put together a
life narrative you know sometimes a
person will start well they're talking
about things in a very positive way and
then are struck that
wait that's not at all i feel like i'm
talking about someone else
right and then they'll realize like oh
because i've shifted into a different
place of what i think about myself right
and if as you said we feel so activated
and beleaguered is a person going to say
the kind thing or the terse thing to
their child right is the person going to
go towards or away from a better job
opportunity right is a person gonna
smile back at the person they like who
they might go out with who smiled at
them right i mean does it change
everything inside into a place where we
feel be leaguered and we don't really
notice right and people will say oh
nothing good is happening to me right
nothing good ever happens to me but but
like okay but good things haven't been
happening since that person has been
hiding themselves from the world
right and we often don't know
why like you know right in the book i
had a woman who loved going to parks and
then her husband passed away when they
were at a walk together at a park and
now you know she can't drive by a
greenery in a park without feeling the
awful tension inside or how my mother
died from pancreatic cancer and then any
word that sounds like that word you know
i wrote in the book where i was going to
the saint pancras my terrible american
accent right rail station in london and
i and i was going to going to meet a
friend and i just like terrible feelings
of like why i didn't want to be there
and i'm thinking oh my gosh do i don't
want to see this person like what what's
going on i realized like the name sounds
like pancreas right so i'm feeling
ashamed of myself what was going on in
my head as i should have gone home more
when my mother was sick and like no i'm
in a terrible place and and you know and
i don't i mean it's only that i've you
know try through my own therapy work to
build up the introspection that would
let me think oh like you're triggered by
something traumatic and you actually do
want to be here you want to see this
person right but that could have gone in
a very different way
when i'm just feeling terrible about all
of it and it's all going over in my head
and it's just simply the triggering of
the name right and like that's not
unique to me right i see this all the
time in people and like if we develop an
understanding of ourselves right then we
can see what's going on inside of me is
anything different how might it have
changed what's changing my body am i
taking care of myself am i healthy the
way that i want to be right am i
sleeping the way that i want to be how
am i being with other people around me
but we've got to start off with a sense
of curiosity about that and an ability
to take stock of what's going on inside
of us without feeling afraid of that
very process
what's your opinion of um
medicines beyond prescription like mdma
or ketamine or psilocybin
any of those kinds of medicines yeah oh
i believe they hold tremendous healing
power and and like any very powerful
tool it has to be they have to be used
very carefully but if you look at the
the data whether it's more recent
research data or it's data from several
decades ago when you really look at and
you see clinical examples of like what
is happening in people what are we able
to do
with those medicines the power
is is extremely high to help people heal
from trauma but we need to figure out
and understand how do we incorporate
that into
the processes that we're already
utilizing and my thought and we are as
as you know our primary clinic is in
portland oregon and as oregon now is
moving towards legalization then we are
moving towards having those arrows in
our quiver too right because we need to
be able to to have all the arrows in the
quiver that one can have to try and help
understand a person whether it's a
clinical or a consulting process right
we want to have all those arrows in the
quiver and be able to bring them to bear
and the arrows that you just mentioned
um have the potential for
a potential for healing that is in many
people and in many situations kind of
off the charts compared to the other
mechanism if you combine of course it's
not just
medicines it's not just a substance
right it's you combine it with with also
the striving for self-understanding for
changing the psycho the psychology uh in
us then the healing that can come if it
all is immense to incorporate therapy
with it i mean what i i mean there are
lots of practitioners that are are using
it in conjunction with therapy is there
is there a favorite do you do would you
say of
of those kinds of medicines outside of
prescription do you have a leader in the
clubhouse for what you think has the
most powerful healing abilities yeah i
think that they're different by person
and by what that person is facing it
seems like what are sort of known as the
psychedelics right that have an ability
to to really change dramatically the
patterns of of communication in our
brains and seat our experience of self
and the world in a place that's deeper
in the brain that's unclouded by a lot
of the survival stuff right the seeking
safety stuff that lets us get at
what has been traumatic in us and can
create healing in ways that that really
are i think previously unimaginable um i
think that they are
they're at this highest end of the power
scale but i do think that mdma and
ketamine they they hold tremendous power
themselves we're just we're coming
further and further down the path of
understanding how you choose one versus
the other and you know circumstances in
person and then and how we safely deploy
those treatments with the psychotherapy
part that's needed so that so that
it's being done safely it's being done
effectively and it's being done um to
really change a person's life for the
better and i mean i think we're we're
really heading towards
understanding how to utilize those
incredibly powerful tools
would you
would you say it was almost like a
shortcut to the truth
by being able to bypass the survival
skills in your
reptilian brain or whatever whatever the
chemical process and the access that
we're we're using in our brain is it
almost like a shortcut i mean i know you
have to get to know your patients i know
these are new therapies and you know
it's uh you've got to tread lightly and
be careful but would you say that it's
it's actually
a preferred route if
safe
i i think
yes in the sense again
yes in the broad sense that that i i
think some of what's happening is the
distress coming from the sort of
reptilian deeper parts of the brain
right but but some of what really ails
us and and gets sort of hijacked by
trauma are actually the outer parts of
the cortex right what we're thinking
what we're planning you know imagine
like that what we think of as the most
advanced human part of the brain that
does executive function and planning
ahead right if that's all hijacked for
like what could happen to me today right
who might do something bad to me today
then we're projecting ahead to all the
scenarios of what could go wrong then we
have the sort of reptilian parts and
what we think of as the more advanced
parts of the brain that are that are
both working against us right and and
what we can do we see this all the time
right and
and if there's a way of quieting the
noise of all of that of all of it and
being seated in a deeper place
then that's how we get the shortcut the
idea of if you're really trying to
listen to something in a piece of music
right and you want to hear it and it's
important but there are six other
speakers playing six different kinds of
music right as most of which you don't
like right then how are you going to
attend to that to the signals that you
really want to hear and think about and
understand and and we can get that way
through traditional medicines and
through psychotherapy but the novel you
know the the novel
medicines right that are now progressing
towards legalization right and we're
studying them and they're progressing
towards legalization
they they offer an opportunity to sort
of quiet the noise coming from those
other speakers right playing just
distraction right that one could then
really commune with and and much better
understand here's what's going on inside
of me and and i see do i feel a sense of
truth to that and people can often have
compassion for themselves and an
understanding of themselves that they
couldn't muster otherwise i mean the
data and the research tells us that and
it tells us that pretty unequivocally
yeah
yeah i think that's that's awesome for
an option as a practitioner and as
patients um it it feels like there's a
an aspect of it that's a lot like emdr
because reading about emdr and body
keeps a score it sort of
you know feels like it's sort of that
access point that allows you to bypass
things and get to
an observer perspective of an event that
was traumatic to you and it's almost
like
you become a time traveler in a way that
you can go back and you can watch
something happen and create a new
sort of a new neural pathway of firing
that is different than when it happened
um what what do you think about emdr
yeah i think it was beautifully put what
you just said and i think that is the
truth of it that that what emdr is
trying to do right and what many of our
helping modalities are trying to do but
specifically what emdr is trying to do
is bypass the things that keep us from
being able to revisit something and
revisit it in a way that we can change
the sort of flags of emotion and meaning
right and the other logical parts of our
brain care very much about the clock in
the calendar right they're logical right
they have to plan and execute on things
right the emotion parts of our brain do
not which is why you know terrible
trauma from 50 years ago can still be
just as immediate in that person's mind
there's a time when i was covering you
know 10 nursing homes or so along the
eastern seaboard of massachusetts and
and when i would see people there with
whom you could do psychotherapy it so
struck me that these traumas even from
childhood it could have been eight
decades ago are still so immediate
because that emotion what's called the
limbic part of the brain that emotional
part of the brain doesn't care about the
clock in the calendar and that can be
used by trauma against us right because
that trauma that happened 20 years ago
may as well have been yesterday right
that's the negative part right but the
positive part is well we can access that
and the brain doesn't say we can't
access that it was 20 years ago right
it'll let us access that and then we can
change the meaning right because the
memories themselves don't have meaning
they're bland and dry they only gain
meaning when they're linked to emotion
so if the memory is linked to an emotion
of shame and an emotion of terror and we
can get at that and we can shift maybe
it's linked to perseverance right or
resilience or even a sense of you know
what something awful happened to me
right
things that were wrong happened they
didn't have anything to say about me or
who i am or what i could do right then
we can go back and change those sort of
flags of emotional meaning and that's
how we can become very empowered right a
sense of agency a sense of sovereignty
right
vis-a-vis things that have been holding
us back or weighing us down for years
it's taking advantage of that hey that
emotional side doesn't care about the
clock and the calendar let's use the
best of the logic and the emotion and
and bring some helping resources to bear
and then we absolutely can change
how people feel and function going
forward i mean it's not always where
there's a there's a miraculous cure but
it's remarkable to see how much better
people across the spectrum do
applying this is kind of well-grounded
hey this is what we know in the field
this is what we know about psychology we
know about brain science and it's what
we know about how to deploy effective
medical care right and and ultimately if
we ground ourselves in common sense we
would do a much better job taking care
of ourselves and having systems that
take care of us than we're doing at the
moment
that's so hopeful
it almost feels like your emotions are
connected to the quantum field and that
can access anything outside of this
time-space reality which is tied to more
of the olympic brain or is the olympic
part of the brain the part the linear
thinking
the logical sort of mechanism than the
limbic is more the emotional part oh the
olympic is the emotional and what's the
thing what's the thing look it's like
l-i-m-d-i-c like linux system is the
emotion system and then there are the
logic systems of our you know prefrontal
cortex the better
there's more in there but that's the
planning ahead and yeah
that seems like it's rooted in this sort
of like
third dimensional world of time-space
reality and like sorry my esoteric brain
gets thinking yeah yeah well the
emotions are connected to the quantum
field that's why you can go to any time
and place and correct it because it's
all
because there's there you you get out of
this time space reality and the
constraints of it yes similarly you can
also manifest really positive things if
you can connect emotionally to something
or something something that you want
it makes me think about heart and brain
coherence that
sort of other spiritual teachers will
talk about which again activates that
emotion um
which is so powerful that's that thank
you i feel like that was a great
explanation help me connect some dots
too
what about um i i would i'm gonna wrap
it up here um but what do you think
about the whole
metaverse
a.i
like that must come into your field and
there must be you must have an opinion
on those and how those affect us
as human beings
i think the evolution of technology
i think is with all technology it gives
us the opportunity to do good things
with it and it also gives us the
opportunity to do very harmful things
with it i mean if you think even the
technology of what we're doing right i
mean we're trying to get good
information out to people right like
there's something you're doing that lets
you reach so many people in a way of
saying hey you're interested in
something you're gonna have to have
thoughtful do you want to listen to a
thoughtful discussion about something
right we're you know we're looking for
facts and understanding like you can get
that out there and that's wonderful
right but the other side of that coin is
that you know how much that's hateful
and you know that is rooted in the
lowest common denominator of people
feeling very badly and then wanting to
alive with other people who feel very
badly and and and have some sense of
superiority right or some you know
something that's that's based in all
this terror and anger in people like we
see that too right so i think that it's
not it was a technology good or bad
right it's what will we do with it and i
think there's the opportunity to do
immense good and we've seen technology
do that right you know other combat
reconstruction right you know scenarios
that help people work through their
combat trauma right and then the
technology plays a big
role there right so there's so much good
the technology can do but there's so
much negative to where people can suffer
virtual trauma right i mean how you know
how close are we to things happening
where people might not be sure is it
really happening to me or not and then
maybe awful things can happen that then
change the brain i mean
we need to be responsible instead of
running headlong into it because look
this much is true that trauma puts
blinders on us right and then that sense
of sovereignty and that sense of
empowerment becomes less and less and
less and what you were just saying of
great these sort of quantal aspects of
the emotions are not tied to time but we
can like harness that and then we can
harness the logical parts of our brain
in a way that really frees us and say i
don't have to have the progressive
blinders to where i see that like this
is all i can do and uh you know we can
take that away and see like that we're
not restricted to the things that trauma
tells us right including our own anger
frustration depression all these things
that come to us and you know it's that
that we want to move forward and i think
technology can help us but
that will only help us if we're also
just grounding to those basics of common
sense too yeah yeah well said well
i'm excited about the horizons of
psychology thank you so much for sharing
your experiences and your knowledge and
allowing uh you know your brother and
his suicide to kind of be an impetus to
helping people and to
um
to sharing what worked and and um and
helping other people get to the other
side of it so
thank you what a fun conversation thank
you so much paul you're welcome thank
you so much i so appreciate it you know
as you as we're saying before i'm a big
fan of yours and i have such admiration
for you and i so appreciate that you
would have me on and that we've been
able to have this conversation thank you
thank you thank you thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the subscribe
button